et des personnes handicapées monsieur le
ministre depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant les EHPAD et plus
généralement l'ensemble des
établissements médico-sociaux sont dans
une situation intenable en plus des
problèmes de recrutement déjà l'attent
avant le covid ces établissements
souffrent de l'inflation et de la crise
énergétique dans ce contexte leurs
dépenses ont exposées elles pourraient y
faire face en ajustant leurs ressources
via une augmentation du prix de journée
mais ce tarif journalier n'augmente
quasiment pas dans ce contexte de
nombreuses établissements associatifs
sont fortement fragilisés et enregistre
des sites élevés par ailleurs plusieurs
catégories de personnels sont toujours
exclus du Ségur certains touchants
depuis plusieurs mois la prime Ségure et
d'autres non
ce déséquilibre a pour conséquence
d'instaurer des tensions entre les
salariés alors même qu'un esprit de
solidarité est nécessaire
disons-le clairement durant le covid les
personnels de ces établissements se sont
montrés exemplaires ils n'ont jamais
fait défaut alors qu'ils étaient en
première ligne
dans ma circonscription j'ai rencontré
les salariés des EHPAD myosotis je
Schweitzer et Sainte-Marie ils m'ont
confié leur déception ils ont le
sentiment que leur dévouement n'est pas
reconnu à sa juste valeur alors que
notre pays a connu plusieurs scandales
ces derniers mois dans des EHPAD privés
il est essentiel aujourd'hui de soutenir
très fortement nos EHPAD associatifs
dans ces circonstances monsieur le
ministre quelles sont les solutions
quelles sont les mesures que vous
proposez afin de leur venir en aide il y
a urgence monsieur le ministre merci
[Applaudissements]